nothing no notes bear with me bear with
me it's really fun to watch conspiracy
theory videos and think about how the
world's out to conspire and beat down
the little man there's one video in
particular that Nikko myself saw
recently even probably saw it yourself
to in its Ethan a K h3h3 s video about
the double standard on YouTube where he
compares Casey night stats video getting
D monetized and then Jimmy Kimmel's
video keepin he's got ads on there so
there's a double standard because
they're both violating the guidelines
now by the end of this video you're
gonna see though that this conversation
in this topic it's a lot more nuanced
than this kind of outraged
black-and-white censorship D
monetization that video is incredibly
misleading ethan himself is actually
woefully misinformed with how youtube's
advertising system actually works
[Music]
you tube if it's your policy to not run
ads on videos about tragedies no matter
the intent then how do you explain this
Jimmy Kimmel mass shooter in Las Vegas
GMC and what Eaton is complaining about
in this video is actually in a way
politically perfect for an illustration
of exactly why he's incorrect YouTube D
monetized video they have a policy of
not monetizing videos about tragedies I
get it it makes sense we can talk more
about that later but then everybody
pointed over to Jimmy Kimmel now he had
made a video talking about the Las Vegas
shooting and he was running ads on that
video outraged hypocrisy YouTube is
screwing over the creator I bring it
your pitchforks clearly there was a
double standard right wrong
YouTube is not running ads on the Jimmy
Kimmel video that story the conspiracy
story it's so easy to rally behind that
that's like that's like yeah yeah big
corporation yeah they're stomping on the
little man yeah it's such an easy sell
anyone won't believe that if you say
that to him it's unfortunately not based
in fact here's what's going on it says
we aren't telling you what to create
each and every creator on YouTube is
unique and contributes to the vibrancy
of YouTube
however advertisers also have a choice
about where to show their ads this works
both ways this works in Google's hand
right now which you've seen with them D
monetizing videos which they deem unfit
for ads but this is also working in this
very same situation with this Jimmy
Kimmel video because there are more than
one way to get an ad on your video the
first way is pretty simple everyone's
familiar with it it's called Google
Adsense your video gets flagged it gets
tagged it gets thrown into this giant
automated system with other videos and
advertisers that get all mixed up and it
spits out ads onto your video based off
of a huge algorithm you've seen that
that's everywhere and Google's got their
hand on that lever and they're
controlling it and so for Casey's video
they shut it off now there's a second
way in which advertising works on
YouTube and that is through selling your
own advertising inventory and most
people don't actually seem to know about
this even steer doesn't you can get
pre-roll ads on your videos by directly
working with companies who want to
advertise on your videos it's happened
on our channel a couple times here and
there we have a
we have someone who's like we love your
audience we love gamers and people who
watch movies and stuff like this so
we're gonna actually work with your MCN
like studio71
and make sure that our ads are featured
in front of your videos
Rory it much further most of these
channels were talking about like Jimmy
Kells is managed by an MC and meaning a
multi-channel network basically some
sort of parent company that is working
with these channels to embedder them
provide ads for them brand's
partnerships relationships
Jimmy Kendall's channel for example
owned by ABC which is owned by Disney
who has their own MC n across YouTube
and a lot of their other channels Disney
is going out and working to him better
to make his channel profitable that is
their goal
Disney has a large ad inventory that
they are selling themselves they are
doing that nav see they're running their
own commercials so what you saw in
YouTube here is not YouTube pulling ads
from KC nice tat and then putting ads on
Jimmy Kimmel and being giant hypocrites
what you're seeing is YouTube's not
running ads on either of these videos
YouTube's not running ads on KC nice
that YouTube's also not running ads at
Jimmy Kimmel the ads running on Jimmy
Kimmel's channel are from ABC and Disney
selling those ads directly to their
advertisers so you actually have
something interesting here you can have
content creators creating controversial
content and if they want to go out and
find advertisers willing to support that
controversial content they can Google is
not actually supporting KC's video or
Jimmy Kimmel's video they are actually
being a hundred percent neutral when it
comes to both of them the only
difference is that Jimmy Kimmel and his
show and his team and his Network are
going out and finding brands that want
to sponsor the video whereas KC is
working independently he is hoping the
automated system will bring the money to
him I'm sure you can find examples of
like oh this one video talked about the
Las Vegas shooting and they have ads
running it's like yeah it's an algorithm
it's an AI there is a rogue AI across
YouTube go ahead destroy no no no you
strangled it's like sorry that's
basically what's happening on YouTube
and it sucks for everyone it's tons of
our videos are getting hit by and it
totally sucks we've actually figured to
a couple ways to kind of ease it for
example you can upload your video maybe
like unlisted you get sent through the
algorithm and the AI checks it out and
if it gets flagged you can dispute it
and send it off a review before your
actual upload date there are ways to
deal with it
it could be an honest mistake because
country is but a lot of this outreach
journalism is not fueled by facts but by
like this emotion and this passion when
you have rules that are so general that
you can prosecute pretty much anyone you
want when you use that broadness to
enforce a certain ideology that's
censorship let's be clear here not
giving a content crater advertiser money
is far different than censorship you're
not entitled to another business's money
they don't owe me anything I don't owe
them anything
obviously their ads run against our
content that's one thing but I can't say
that they must put their ads on my video
and if they don't they're censoring me
no that's not how it works
funny thing is like the casein ice that
video where they didn't have run any ads
on it that's costing YouTube money in
fact any video that YouTube doesn't run
ads on they are actually taking a hit in
order to keep controversial content live
on their system because they're not
making any more ad revenue on that
bandwidth that they're hosting in the
server space if the videos are taking up
which is kind of funny if you think
about it they're maybe not paying the
creator's to do so which makes sense but
that's quite the opposite of censorship
imagine if you will you make a video
find an injustice in the world and you
bring it to light and you get millions
of views Wow everybody really liked that
I exposed it to the world and rally
people around it I'll do it again
you make another video find another
injustice you get a million more views
you make a bunch of money I should do
this every week so every week you're
finding a new outrage a new injustice
and you know what after a while it's
hard to do that research it's hard to
find a new injustice every single time
so you kind of like fudge it a little
bit here and there and you don't worry
about doing your research too much here
and there and you go off the cuff here
and there and suddenly you've rallied a
million people into a frothy mob angry
at this one person for doing this thing
wrong and that's what YouTube's trying
to avoid here by D monetizing those kind
of videos so trying to not incentivize
people to create outrage journalism for
the sake of making a buck which is
exactly what happened here with Ethan
yeah I mean he fell into it himself I
mean that headline you know double
standard on YouTube for advertising it's
like well there's a lot of people who
are getting that little yellow dollar
sign including ourselves so it's it's a
very easy click I mean I saw it was like
ooh this is gonna be juicy and I watched
it and at first I was like yeah that
double standard and I was like oh wait
that's not what's going on
quickly think about the information
people
you look for the faults view it from the
other point of view if possible even
this video it's healthy to be a little
bit skeptical it's healthy to take some
time and quickly think about what people
are saying okay yeah but seriously
thanks is YouTube for sponsoring this
video I'm hoping thanks for the ad on
this video YouTube I hope it makes you
proud also Ethan I love you so here's
another kind of interesting thing to
think about a little thought experiment
if you will out of all the viewers that
watch that a tree a tree video the one
said upset how many of them do you think
of running adblock is that not the exact
same thing we all depend on revenue and
advertising on our channels to make
money is our it's our careers and our
livelihood we care a lot about it the
h3h3 video we've tried to approach this
as factually and objectively as possible
because it's a very emotional topic for
a lot of people we talked about our
objective facts here but we haven't
really gotten too much into the morals
and what we think the ideals of YouTube
should be here I think that's really
what this question is all about do I
believe that YouTube is treating people
unfairly and I would say yes smaller
channels got D monetized first before
large channels we sweets not having and
we know that smaller channels are also
having a huge pain trying to contest all
these flags that are happening on their
channel so are people on smaller
channels being treated unfairly yes but
when it comes to this other standard
this other double standard here this
isn't a matter of unfairness Jimmy
Kimmel he gets added to on his videos
because he has a large company that is
funneling ads and in choosing to
advertise on his videos you could say
that's corporate favoritism but I would
actually call that freedom while Adsense
might be revoked for a lot of channels
YouTube is still allowing a certain
amount of freedom freedom for you to
talk about a controversial topic and go
out and find someone to support you and
that is that is a type of freedom that I
actually fully support because if
YouTube suddenly came out and said you
know what any video any video that we as
Google find controversial we're not
going to allow you to profit off of now
that that is an actual manner of
totalitarian control and that is what is
unfair this all can be boiled down into
one pretty simple question which is if
you want to make controversial content
something that someone else seems
controversial but you're able to find
a brand a company someone who's willing
to support that content should YouTube
be able to stop you from doing that let
us know what you think in the comments
we took our best efforts to make this
factual and objective this topic is so
much broader than we could fit into just
this video so we are going to make some
follow ups subscribe to this channel if
you want to learn more about the ad
pocalypse even on the off chance that
you happen to be watching this I hope
you that you respect that we're
providing a criticism and a counterpoint
it seems like something you yourself had
actually encouraged so thanks for
watching